why the British starved the Indians, explained like you are five.
Step one, 1858, Britain takes direct control of India.
300 million people, the richest subcontinent on earth,
spices, cotton, opium, tea, textiles, gold, Britain extracts it all.
Historians estimate Britain drains $45 trillion from India over 200 years,
the most profitable colony in human history.
India feeds Britain's industrial revolution.
India fights Britain's wars.
India builds Britain's railways with Indian labor and Indian money.
And pays for the privilege through a tax system designed to transfer wealth upward
to British landlords, British administrators, British shareholders,
the people growing the food taxed so heavily they cannot afford to eat it.
The system works perfectly until the rains stop.
Step two, 1876, the monsoon fails across southern India.
Crops wither, wells dry up, people begin to starve.
The British response is immediate and precise.
They do almost nothing.
The Viceroy Lord Lytton is a follower of free market economics.
He believes government intervention in food markets distorts prices.
So while Indians starve, grain sits in warehouses.
While Indians starve, food is loaded onto ships and exported to Britain,
not because Britain needs it, because the market says it is more profitable there.
In 1877, at the height of the famine, Lord Lytton hosts a banquet for 68,000 people
to celebrate Queen Victoria being declared Empress of India.
The banquet lasts one week.
Outside, bodies in the streets.
Step three, the famine of 1876 kills 5.5 million people.
Before India recovers, another famine, 1896, then again 1899.
Three catastrophic famines in 25 years, 29 million dead in total.
Each time, the same pattern, food available, food exported, people die.
One British official, Sir Richard Temple, tries to set up famine relief camps.
He is removed from his position, criticized for being too generous with Indian lives.
His replacement cuts rations below what the Nazis later feed concentration camp
prisoners and introduces a rule.
Anyone who walks more than 10 miles to reach a relief camp is too healthy to need relief
and is turned away.
The camps become death camps.
The official name, the famine code.
Step four, Winston Churchill becomes Secretary of State for India in 1940.
Another famine strikes Bengal.
Three million people die.
Churchill diverts food shipments away from India to British troops and European stockpiles.
When told of the mass deaths, he asks why Gandhi hasn't died yet.
He writes in a memo that Indians are a beastly people with a beastly religion
who brought the famine on themselves by breeding like rabbits.
After independence, India never has a famine again, not one.
In 75 years, the famines were not caused by drought.
They were not caused by overpopulation.
They were caused by policy, deliberate, documented, defended at the time.
29 million people in the richest colony the world had ever seen,
starved to death by the people running it.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Download it now and become the most intelligent person in the room.